- [Mark] So Riley, where did you grow up?
- I was born in Hollywood,
and I was raised at the (indistinct).
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
- Oh, I don't remember most of it,
because I was tortured and molested
from like I don't know-
- [Mark] You were?
tortured and molested from a
very young age up to about 16.
- [Mark] Oh really, who was doing that?
- My father and stepfather,
separately of course.
- [Mark] Your father and stepfather?
- Yeah (indistinct).
You know my stepfather
he used to do things
like put me in the trunk of the car
to scare me or fold me up
in a sofa bed so that...
Just to terrify me so that
I wouldn't say anything,
and I didn't remember what my father did,
I put all of those on to my stepfather.
Everything was on my stepfather,
until I got older and I started
to come to the realization.
- [Mark] (indistinct).
- There was...
Oh yeah.
- I have really bad P.T.S.D,
due to the fact that my stepfather,
so they were doing this
psych little study on me
or whatever.
They found that they would
take me back to those times
and finally one of the psychiatrists says,
"Enough's enough, so we get
her back there then what?"
"Then she's just rehashing it,
reliving it and then we sit around,
and go to dinner and have
some drinks at the bar
and she's a mess."
So he said, "Why don't we do it like this,
I want you to sit down
and I want you to imagine
that those people that did
those horrible things to you,
were now in the same situation
that you were with them."
Something horrible is happening
to them and their children,
because nobody just wakes and says
they're gonna torture and molest children.
Some kind of strange mental
twist happens to them
and from that point forward,
they need to do these
things that are heinous.
So I imagine them as little kids,
bad things happened to them,
and I was able to let go off the hatred.
Because only I suffer from hatred
they don't know what's going on,
they're off on their life having fun.
- [Mark] How old were
you when you left home?
Oh, I was...
Graduated sixteen.
Sixteen and I moved to the big city.
Right, so I left and I hit the streets
of places like Hollywood
and those kind of places (clears throat).
So after that I got a job dancing
at those Diamond Dance Clubs.
- [Mark] You worked at dance clubs?
- Diamond Dance Clubs and
stripping and stuff like that
and I started dealing.
Bigger connections so someone told me
that the Mexican Mafia was at
the Alexandria Hotel downtown
and I could get a big connection there.
So back in the day I had a
body that was kind of bangin'
so I went down to this
hotel and rented a room.
I ended up meeting and getting involved
with the Mexican Mafia somehow (laughs).
- [Mark] That's when you sold drugs?
Yeah selling drugs to all
the girls in the dance clubs.
- [Mark] How was that?
And you are using crack cocaine.
Yeah that's my medication.
I had a psychiatrist tell me one time,
"If I could prescribe you
crack I would do that."
'Cause it seems just to work for me.
- [Mark] It makes you what, more calm?
- Everyone else who smokes
it is tweaking and skinny,
and when I smoke crack I'm
calm and I eat (laughs).
- [Mark] And for money you go?
- I prostitute (laughs).
And dominatrix and-
- [Mark] I heard
through the grapevine that
you've had some interesting experiences
with guys you've picked up.
- Yeah, I've survived four serial killers
that nobody else has.
- [Mark] You've survived
four serial killers?
- Yeah, well some people
first off understand this
they're not far and few between,
serial killers are not
far and few between.
There are thousands of them
right here right now in Los Angeles.
- [Mark] Yeah and they
come in this neighborhood.
These girls are
dispensable with him right?
- Right.
- [Mark] (indistinct).
- Right and the thing is this,
I know that when someone picks
me up to do something foul,
they've done it many times before.
Because I would not be my first choice
to do something like that.
I'd get some petite,
frail, timid little girl.
I wouldn't get one that
I thought could fight me back so (laughs).
When I get scared my brain
goes, 'Fight, protect yourself,
do what you have to do, bite,
scratch, kick, whatever,
gouge out eyes, screw about
their throat, anything.'
Some people when they get scared freeze.
- [Mark] So tell me a story.
Okay yeah I was actually in a hotel
over by the Alvorado area.
I was with a customer and I
took off to go get some crack,
and on my way back this man
stops me in this gold honda.
He was Korean, he was 6'2 or 6'3,
he was not stocky but really athletic.
He was very cut, very
unusual for a Korean person.
He looked like a college student
or a olympian in training.
So, he pulled up and he asked me
if I would give him head for $80
and he hands me an envelope.
I had this customer, he
has money back at the hotel
but I couldn't pass up the
chance for this extra $80.
So I get in the car, and he
drives and parks the car,
and I went to go down to give him head
and all of a sudden
lightening flew out of my eyes
and I sat up and my head was spinning.
And something was bothering me
in the back of my head I
reached back like this,
Oh there's something there.
I pulled it out and it
was the claw of a hammer
that he had stuck in the back of my head.
- [Mark] Which part of the hammer?
The claw part had sunken
in the back of my head.
I sat up and I had this hammer in my hand
and within moments the entire
car was saturated with blood.
We were slipping and sliding,
I wanted to put the
hammer down to fight him
but I was afraid he might pick it up
and start hitting me with it.
So I'm hitting him with his
hammer and he's fighting me
and all of a sudden he says
to me, "Get out of the car."
That didn't even dawn
on me before that point,
I was in shock, I had a head trauma.
So, my thinking was 'No I'm gonna die
and I'm gonna make sure you go with me.'
And then I thought well
maybe I'm not gonna die
maybe I get out of his car
before I pass out I can live.
I better do that.
So I tell him, "Open my door."
So he leans over and he
opens my door and I fall out,
and I started screaming,
"Help me, the building's on
fire and my baby's in there."
You know you can just say
help and nobody will help,
but if the building...
It might be their building is on fire,
you hear what I'm saying.
And so I stumbled up the street
and I was covered in
blood from head to toe
just sopping in blood.
And a taxi goes driving
by and I hail this taxi,
and he says to me, "Oh no,
you get out of the car,
or you give me head."
And I thought...
I just remembered I had a boot...
A knife in my boot that morning
so I pulled this knife out
and I stick it in his throat just enough
so it draws a little blood.
I said "Listen, this
is how it's gonna go."
And I reached out and I
took out twenty dollars
and I threw it in his seat.
Then I said, "You're going
to drive me about five blocks
from here and you're
going to not say a word
to make me lose my faith
in humanity and further."
Because if you do,
I'll just push a little
deeper into your throat,
and worry about how to
get the car over later.
And so he silently drove me over
and dropped me off and I got
out and went to this hotel.
And when I went in, I
remember my customer saying
he was an upper class kind
of individual he says,
"You need to go to the hospital."
Right yeah.
Next thing I know I wake up or
I come to and I'm in this bed
and he's taking everything
except for some dope I'd hidden.
It took me 45 minutes in the shower
to get this pillow unstuck from my head,
because it was stuck in the whole there.
- [Mark] A pillow case?
- No, the pillow, not the
whole pillow you know,
when I slept the blood dried
and you know what I'm saying,
and I could just pull it
because I'm not quite
sure what's hanging out
or what's going on so I stand
in the shower for 45 minutes
until I get the pillow
unstuck from my head
and I get dressed.
I put a little hat on
and try to make myself
as cute as possible and go out and work.
- [Mark] You went out
on the street to work?
- I had to go out to work because
it was now check out time,
45 minutes prior to that.
- [Mark] What about going to the hospital?
- I couldn't do that
without money in my pocket.
- [Mark] You've got to
make some money first?
- Right absolutely.
So I go out it's by Alvarado
and this man picks me up,
I get in the car and he pays
me and I go to give him head,
except for this time, very gently he went
to touch the back of my
head and blood just went
all down my face and his crotch
and he was screaming, I was screaming.
Yeah I've got to clean myself
up, so I get out of the car,
I apologize to this man, he said,
"Keep the money, keep the money."
I clean myself up at a fire hydrant,
so I get into McDonald's,
I clean myself up and I go back
out 'cause I have some money
and I have to buy some clothes (chuckles).
And so, this homicide detective,
comes driving down the street
and he pulls up and he says,
"You know, you need to be really careful,
there's a man out here killing women."
I go, "Really, does he use a hammer?"
And his face turned gray.
And he said, "What do you know
about a man attacking
women with a hammer?"
And I turned around and shook
the little hat off my head
and I said, "Because he hit me with it."
And he says, "Can you identify him?"
I go, "I've got his fingerprints,
would you like the hammer?"
He had wrapped it with
gauze and in the struggle
and all the wetness it kind of slid off,
so his fingerprints were really...
So I gave him that and
he put me in the car,
and took me to the hospital
and dropped me off.
The doctor said I was really really lucky,
the only reason I survived that concussion
was the hole in my head
released the pressure.
- [Mark] (indistinct).
- Right, good thing for that.
- [Mark] Did they ever catch the guy?
- Oh yeah, they had his fingerprints
and they had his driver's license,
I didn't have to testify or
anything because with him,
there was so much...
He gave up the location of like,
14 more bodies, they knew of 12,
to take the death penalty off the table.
So they gave him like
6000 years plus 400 more
or something like that, so
he'll never get out yeah,
I survived.
And the thing is you just
have to keep going on,
people go yeah I had a hole in my head now
what do I do just lay down?
I had to just keep going,
I had to persevere somehow
I had to keep going forward
and that's what I did.
- [Mark] And you had more than one?
- Yes right, I had another
one that was in Chinatown.
A Salvadorian man, he picked me up,
he was the manager of
an apartment building
on Ord Street in Chinatown.
I thought that was kind of strange,
so we get into this apartment building
and it's about eight
O'clock in the morning.
And we go up there and I walk in the door
and every inch of the walls is covered
with pictures of him and
his family in military gear.
You know in El Salvador, you
know buddy buddy pictures,
and you know all these
different kinds of pictures,
it was bizarre (laughs).
And so I said, okay some...
He hands me a beer and I go,
"Okay, but I need my money please."
He goes, "Oh your money,
you'll get no money,
I'm gonna take your money,
your pussy and your life."
I went like this, so I
start screaming right,
because he hits me in
the head with a bottle.
So I started screaming,
if I'm gonna die everybody
is gonna hear me die.
So I'm screaming and people
are beating on the door,
and he goes,
"You can scream all you want,
I'll kill them all here,
nobody will help you."
And my brain went (indistinct).
- [Mark] He said what?
- He said, "You can scream all you want,
I'll kill them all here,
nobody is gonna help you."
And my brain went (laughs).
And I just started fighting.
He tackled me,
now this was a kind of squatty,
stocky kind of guy, really strong.
Now he's got me on my back okay,
between a dresser and a bed,
and I'm like a snow angel doing this.
Anything I can get my hands
on I'm hitting him with it.
And finally I got my hands
and he's got his thumb
and he's choking me out.
And so finally I get a hold of the bottle
and I hit him and I went...
I cut him from here to here,
his face fell forward on him
and blood is just pouring on me.
And were fighting, he's still fighting,
his face is I don't know
how he didn't have vertigo or something,
but I guess the eyes didn't get cut,
it was just the skin flapped forward,
kind of like scalping but
more of a facing (laughs).
Were fighting and finally he says,
"Now I'm fighting for 24 minutes
because I'm looking at this
digital clock on the wall."
And he's like 24 minutes of fighting,
it was like professional
boxers don't even do that.
I was using every molecule
in my being to survive this.
Finally he tells me to get out,
well that sounded really
good to me (laughs).
So I get up and I run to the door
and I open the door and
I turn around to look
and he's coming at me with a machete.
Not one of those old Cuban,
gonna whack a piece of plantain off the...
No this was a techno,
green with this sharp blade
I could see glistening with a sharp edge.
So I ran, I opened the door, two alleys,
two alleys which way, down
the stairs out the front door,
and I'm now in Chinatown again.
10 O'clock in the morning,
whatever it is 9 O'clock in the morning.
- [Mark] You have clothes on?
- Well I had a basketball
throwback jersey on,
it was very thick and it was ripped,
I don't know how he ripped
this, but it was ripped.
I go out there and I'm covered again
now head to toe in blood (trembling).
Help, no, no busy, everybody's too busy,
so I run to the corner to a pay phone
and I pick up the phone and I dial 9-1-1.
And they answer and I can't talk
because my brain is in overload
and every time somebody came
around the corner I was like.
Because I don't know
who's on my team you know,
so finally they trace the phone,
they send the paramedics
over that boxy truck,
and I ran over and opened the back door
and jumped in and put my back
against the wall (panting).
At first, this older Black
police officer showed up
and he wasn't very amused
that he had to come deal
with this.
And he said, "Can you identify him?"
And I went, "Two, two."
I spit out the room number
and he went up there
and when he came back,
he was a completely different
individual towards me.
He was like, "Sweety
it's gonna be all right,
don't you worry about a thing."
They had found there was blood snow angel
on the floor from me
trying to fight this guy.
And all the blood made this
snow angel on the floor
and splattered blood like
wings up against the wall.
And he said, "You won't
have to do anything,
the pictures alone will,
you know what I'm saying?"
At first they couldn't tell
what was wrong with me,
because nothing brought me around,
no smelling salts, nothing
like that I was just out.
I was fighting for 24 minutes
with every molecule of my
being, of course I was out.
There was no crack in my system
now, I fought, I was tired,
I was gonna go to sleep,
yeah that guy, he killed
six that they know of.
26, 16 and 6 (indistinct).
- [Mark] What's 26, 16 and 6?
- How many people these guys have killed.
- [Mark] The asian guy killed 26 people.
- And you know what's really amazing is
you'll never hear about it on the news.
- [Mark] I've heard so many stories
from the women down here.
- It was the beginning
of re-gentrification
and they were not gonna tell it.
- [Mark] They don't want to publicize it.
So how many years have
you been on crack cocaine?
- (exhales heavily) I've
been on crack cocaine
since the early 80s, 1980, 1982, so yeah.
- [Mark] You've done prison time?
- Yeah, in '89 and '99.
- [Mark] What for, possession?
- Sales yeah.
- [Mark] Sales?
Have you ever been clean?
I've had like eight years
and four years, yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have children?
- I have one child.
- [Mark] You have a son?
- Yes he's 35.
- [Mark] 35, did you raise him?
- No, only for the first
couple of years of his life,
and then my stepmother, she raised him.
- [Mark] And he's okay?
- Mh-hmm.
- [Mark] You talk to him?
- I haven't talked to him
for a few months, but yeah.
- [Mark] How much do you think
your childhood experiences
with your parents and how your stepdad
have effected the
situation you're in today?
- Unfortunately a great deal.
Even though I know, I'm
intelligent but intelligence
has nothing to do with any of that.
So I know textbook 101 psychology
that still I can't seem
to make (indistinct).
I get very emotional, I
cry at the drop of a hat,
yeah I try not to, I'm
trying to talk slow too.
If I could speak as quickly as my brain
is functioning my hair
would be on fucking fire.
- [Mark] Your hair is already on fire.
- Is it?
- [Mark] It's bright red.
- I'm glad we had the time together.
(both laughing)
- [Mark] All right, we thank
you so much for passing by.
- [Riley] Thank you very much.
- [Mark] And talking slowly this time.
- Was it better?
- There is much (indistinct).
- (exhales heavily) Okay.
- [Mark] (indistinct).
- Oh yes.
- [Mark] All right.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Thank you so much.
- Thank you ooh.
(footsteps pattering)